- I'm here for the carbs.
(wooshing)
(Italian music)
- Being broke in college,
definitely think a pasta
is a necessity, I don't think
I would have made it through
if I didn't eat a lot of pasta.
- I think I'm gonna do terrible.
- I like to set expectations up for myself
kind of like in the mid
range, 'cause then no one
can be disappointed.
- Just looking at all
three of these pastas,
they look exactly the same.
Even the smell is the same.
(Italian music)
(dinging)
- The pasta sauce here smells tomato-y,
which is a good start.
- That tastes like pasta.
- This definitely is like,
I wanna say it's hearty.
It doesn't remind me of college
so it must be more expensive.
- A taste as if the tomatoes were plucked
underneath the Tuscan sun, I'm
gonna say that's expensive.
- I like this one.
Definitely contrasting with
the saltiness of this one.
- Definitely more water in this one.
It's probably a little cheaper.
- I don't know, I'm not a chef.
- Hmm, I wanna get it
right 'cause it's my pride.
- Yeah, this one is more
expensive than this one.
I can tell.
(buzzing)
This one, tastes a little bit more herby.
- Okay, this one barely
tasted like anything at all.
I feel like I got a hint of tomato.
- Okay, I think I got this one, okay.
Can I go ahead and do this?
- So I'm guessing this
is the expensive one.
(dinging)
- This one I'm like yes, this
takes me back to my birthdays
in the dorm room so this
has to be the cheapest one.
(buzzing)
It has to be.
- I'm gonna go with the expensive one is
the one that I liked.
(buzzing)
- This one's the cheapest
one, I'm gonna say.
I'm just gonna go ahead
and decide this now.
(buzzing)
You are cheap.
- Let's switch these two around.
(dinging)
- How did I do?
(buzzing)
What?
Shut up, this is the most?
This is $11?
You are paying for nothing, Oh my god no.
No, no, no, no, no!
- This is the cheapest one?
- I'm very proud of myself,
like literally this tasted like nothing,
it was like olive oil and
tomatoes, and in my head,
I was like, what do fancy people like?
They just like the
quality of the ingredients
is so fresh, we just
wanted to let it breathe.
- I still like Prego.
But I'm very shocked that
that was the only one
I got right.
- Oh well.
I didn't say I was an expert in this.
I just said I'm here for the carbs.
So I didn't disappoint anyone.
- Wow, that blows my mind.
That, that's blasphemy, that's wrong.
- To be honest, it's a little bland.
This one's a little bland,
I'm just gonna say it.
(wooshing)